this is how you as a student still receive a subsidy
for the high energy costs
has the energy price ceiling for you
also little sense
because your dorm 1 joint
has energy connection
now there is 1 temporary allowance
for everyone
with such a common block connection
that can make a lot of money
but you have to be quick
because the application deadline is already October 31
applications must be made by your landlord
it is very important
to urge your landlord to request this
if you rent from 1 private individual
it is very useful
just 1 email
to ask if this has already been done
check the blog on skiraccident
com for 1 sample email
and for 1 skill student
for more content about money like this